alright guys so they released the Thor
the dark world trailer today and as you
know with these superhero films I am
obviously very excited to see them
because I am a nerd and I enjoy that
type of entertainment so I rushed to my
iPhone believe it or not and watched it
and I was just like staring and you know
what I'm very satisfied with what I see
the plot that this trailer hints at is
that some sort of dark force at one
point in time was like the only thing in
existence before the universe was in
existence and apparently this thing
whatever this this dark force is has
survived and it's now coming to wreak
havoc you seen the trailer that Thor
comes back to earth again to pick up
natalie portman please excuse my
nerdgasm I apologize but apparently Thor
can come back to earth just like he did
in the Avengers despite the fact that in
Thor the first film the Bifrost was
destroyed I don't really think they got
into that they just was one little line
where they kind of hinted that he had to
fix it or whatever's to kind of gloss
that over and now there's some sort of
war going on between this dark force and
for an Asgard now the first Thor film I
did like I thought I had room for
improvement though it could have been
better with some of the direction it
could be better was some of the plot all
the Asgard stuff was really cool and
once I got onto earth there were some
funny humorous moments to be had but I
really felt like the film lost a little
bit of its structure despite the fact
that I overall did enjoy Thor I thought
there was room for improvement and based
on this trailer it looks like we're
gonna get that the special effects look
very very good already and the film
doesn't even come out till November and
these effects already look fantastic
Chris Hemsworth is a really good actor
he's proven that he can do things not
just Thor but other roles as well and I
want to see him do more still as an
actor I want to see him outside of the
whole action II kind of thing but I
really do think he is great as this
character and once again he's looking
really good in the role the trailer also
suggests that Natalie Portman's
character will at some point in the film
come into some sort of danger which you
know if you've ever seen a movie in your
life in which there is a big strong male
character and he likes a girl more than
likely that girl is going to become a
damsel in distress at some point that
can take the film in interesting
directions I'm not sure what they're
gonna do with that you could get some
real raw emotion out of that and I hope
they achieve that really well it looks
like what they're hinting at that they
will but what really sold me on this
trailer was the end of it you get a look
at Loki and you get a suggestion that
these two guys are gonna have to work
together
know that when you betray me I would
kill you when do we stop now Loki is one
of the coolest villains that I've seen
in recent years and Tom Hiddleston
played him so so well and I think that's
a great way to expand upon both of their
characters learn more about their past
and give them a different type of future
they may have had and I really like that
because audiences really loved Loki and
I really liked the idea of him sort of
being right on that line of good and
Matt because he's like the perfect
character for that and I really really
like that that's a great idea
and I can't wait to see where the film
takes that idea so I'm excited for Thor
I wish it came out sooner than November
but hey you know it's gonna be
interesting to have a superhero film
that late in the year and maybe it'll be
Oscar nominee but seriously guys what do
you think of the Thor trailer I enjoyed
it let me know your comments below will
your thoughts on the first film if you
want to tell me that's cool too and as
always guys if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck menage